good afternoon everyone I'm reliably
informed it is 3:30 so we can start
first apologies for absence mr. chairman
got apologies from councillor Junaid and
comes laquetta
Thank You disclosures of interest do we
have any disclosures of interest
councillor Perry good afternoon chair
leader just to advise I have received
some information from the Shakespeare
line promotion through the mail probably
sent to walk all cabinet members yes
right minutes confirm and find the
minutes from the meeting held on the 8th
of April is everyone who is here happy
with the minutes a great thank you
[Music]
before we get into the agenda proper
there are two things one I've got some
announcements and a second we've got a
public speaker so first off with the
announcements I would actually like to
express my thanks to Isabella
Edgar Branson for her contribution to
Stratford District Council and wish her
every success in a new role in reading
then I'm sure a cabinet will support me
in this right now turning to what we are
proposing to do mr. Buckland will move
across to be head of paid service on the
temporary basis and we will recruit an
interim Section 1 5 1 officer timescales
would indicate we will not be able to
recruit a permanent section 1 5 1
officer until February next year the
medium-term financial planner process
will start in August September and
continue through to March next year
there will be a need for continuity in
that role to make sure we get a thorough
job done and of course this one is
really important as it will set the tone
for the
next four years we also need to consider
the organization structure we need and
all the implications of the interim
arrangements this will be on the agenda
for the employment and appointments
committee on the 9th of July so that's
what we are proposing to do and
employment and appointment committee
will consider the way forward after that
and then I am well aware we have three
totally new counselors around the
cabinet table so perhaps they would like
just to introduce themselves and give a
brief summary of their CV so if we start
with you counselor dr. Harvey Thank You
chairman
Trevor Harvey first degree economics
from London second degree an MBA from
Cranfield third degree an MA from
Birmingham fourth degree PhD from
Birmingham former fellow of the
Chartered Institute of bankers form a
member of the Chartered Institute of
Personnel and development currently
fellow of the Royal Historical Society
last job was for about 20 years as
director of Ashford Business School
where I was both director of the
management team and a trustee of the
pension scheme Thank You chairman
councilor Shenton Thank You mr. chairman
I'm not sure I can follow that
I am just I'm just a humble accountant
or a chartered accountant by profession
and I've worked in industry for the last
40 years and also probably a bit longer
than that for various sites companies
from small companies ranging to
multi-billion pound companies in various
positions up to finance director and
currently I'm actually building my own
practice now again and I've been a
magistrate community first responder
within the area and worked for the nfu
which is a local company and a few
mutual know so I will say and a number
of big engineering companies around the
West Midlands so that's my my background
if anybody were I cannot follow that
string of qualifications with any more
than laughing Thank You councillor
Shenton a humble accountant I will
remember that councillor Whaley Huggins
I do have an honours degree from
Lancaster University I was born and
brought up in Bradford although I've
spent any twenty-five years down here my
first career was in with the West
Yorkshire Police where as a police
officer serving in the inner city of
Bradford and some rural districts
including Todmorden which you might
remember from the great horse meat
scandal a few years ago I wasn't
surprised when Todd wouldn't was listed
as one of those areas I have an
exemplary service record and I am quite
used to putting on a riot gear and I am
quite literally bomb-proof then moved on
to my teaching career which has been
done in a diverse range of schools from
inner-city Coventry to our more rural
areas of Oxfordshire within my teaching
career I've worked for the British
Council and travel to Malaysia where
I've been working where I've worked with
the government's curriculum development
council
and I've had a lot of fun affiliation
for the area through through family
links so through my teaching I have
familiar with one of the earliest
candidates for the national professional
qualification of headship which helps on
to manage extremely large budgets and of
course people projects and other
important matters thank you - Thank You
councillor Huggins I think everyone else
is well known to the people around the
table so without further ado we will
move on to the public speaker and we
have mr. Tom Baxter chairman of
Stratford Greenway group so if you all
right sorry I understand you speaking on
that item thank you so much is referred
to be referred to council deputy leader
place development requirements
supplementary planning document thank
you Jeff
and I speak merely as a Brahmi boy item
for for the cabinet today is the latest
in a series of documents development
requirements supplementary planning
documents members of cabinets will be
aware that as part of the core strategy
we have to bring forward a detailed
planning documents these are documents
that sort of help give life and shape to
the overall core strategy and ensure
that we have development in the right
place so for example in in the
conservation area of Stratford we don't
build a Hong Kong garden today we're
looking at part H I K 0 and R which are
adopting our detailed policies in
relation to shop fronts and retail
non-residential buildings holiday let's
and Caravan homes parking and travel
standards and air quality
so far we have adopted 16 other parts of
the supplementary planning documents and
these five parts form the remaining
parts of the SPD to conclude that police
of work the recommendation which will go
to full Council is that this council
formally adopts parts H I K 0 and r of
the development requirements
supplementary planning documents happy
to take any questions or queries from
members of cabinet ok cabinet any
questions comments or observations if
there are non can I take it there and
that the development requirements
supplementary planning document is
recommended to Council for formal
adoption thank you
cabinets so moving on community
infrastructure levy spending
arrangements and once again it is
councillor Pemberton Thank You chair and
leader members of the cabinet will be
aware that we have a community
infrastructure levy that is in place has
been through examination by inspector
and is adopted as part and parcel of our
arrangements to secure infrastructure
spending on development this item seeks
to bring forward a minimum threshold
before which spending is engaged profile
thus far is that at this point funds are
coming in in not quite dribs and drabs
but in unequal and sporadic amounts
there is work that needs to be done to
assess against our what is called 1 2 3
list which is the overarching list of
sil projects it's felt by officers that
we need to get to a sort of critical
mass of funds that are available for
spending and therefore the
recommendation is to endorse an
amendment to the community
infrastructure levy spending
arrangements which are attached at
Appendix 1 to introduce a 750,000 pound
minimum threshold of available
funds before the process of allocation
and spend is undertaken and that this be
reviewed on the 1st of April each year
and once again if anybody has any
questions or queries Chancellor Cargill
thank you I quite agree with the the
minimum threshold to start up the PATA
so to speak oh can I just query how are
we going to then spend this money are we
going to always have a minimum of 750 in
the pot Thank You councillor cargill I
had a suspicion that you would raise
this question and the answer is that as
you'll see at the the final part of the
recommendation there is a mechanism to
review how this actually works and
whether it is a case of topping up so I
think the answer is we need to get to
some critical mass to actually start to
disseminate funds and thereafter we will
keep the matter under under review and
review and revise the process Thank You
chairman a simple question have you got
any estimate of the amount of time it
will be before a few weeks a few months
a few years
thank you very much Chancellor gray and
I mean that much to some degree is in
the the lap of developers bringing
forward developments because that's a
consequence of development just for some
background to largest developments in
terms of new settlements carriers
zero-rating for sales that's guiding
light on teeth and long lasting so it is
the sort of the major sites that we
bring forward so it is anticipated that
some at some point during I think this
this municipal year we will be looking
to to disseminate funds but that is to
some degree beholden to developments
coming forward and Silve being triggered
pemberton we are expecting to reach the
threshold of 750,000 during the current
financial year so we are expecting to
launch this first billion bounty they
for 2020 counselors Shenton confirmation
this doesn't affect the parishes in any
way they still get their the
contribution fifteen or twenty five
percent they're not bound going to be
tied up in this in any way correct okay
without members of cabinet any more
questions comments or observations in
that case cabinet can I have your
agreement to the recommendation on page
eleven to endorse the amended civil
spending arrangements attached as
Appendix one which introduces a seven
hundred and fifty thousand minimum
threshold of available sale thumbs
before the process for allocation and
spend ease undertaking to be reviewed on
the 1st of April each year can I have
your agreement please thank you members
of cabinet so moving on to item six and
once again this is councillor Pemberton
and this is the Gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessment 2019 to 2035
thank you chair and leader this brings
forward a piece of technical evidence
that will help us in bringing forward
the identification of sites to meet the
requirement that we have to address the
needs of gypsies travelers and traveling
showmen which is another category that
are common and under this particular
piece of work the key area I think for
members to to be drawn towards is
arising out of a changing evidence base
the there are depth there are widening
definitions of gypsies and travellers
there is and that then creates different
levels of potential need for low
authorities to address in essence there
is there is a narrow definition a
mid-range definition and a far more
wide-ranging definition at this point it
is the recommendation that we should be
following the the middle course and in
essence as and when policy changes or
case law changes that requires us to
address the wide arranging definition we
can actually use the concept of reserved
sights to address any any change in that
so so members the recommendation here is
that we we take this as a piece of
evidence and then there's an that then
takes us into the further stage in terms
of bringing forward the discussions
around actual sites so the
recommendation is that the
stratford-upon-avon gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessment known as the
GTAA for the period 2019 to 2035 but
received as technical evidence to inform
planning decisions and policy
developments in housing and planning
notably the emerging gypsy and traveller
plan and again any questions Callie
Cargill thank you Thank You Kathy as you
know we've been involved in this
particular process now for some time I'm
quite happy to go along with the
reviewing in the report I'd just like to
really I suppose discuss a few of the
problems we are experiencing at
certainly counter that but my my over
hat on on sites that are larger sites
and I think once you get to large
sometimes we start to see more and more
problems occurring the other thing I'd
say is that we this is only a start we
need to get the NGO called for sites at
the gain but we have no sites coming
forward what's going to happen are we
going to go to appeal again are we going
to you're an inspector and I'm just
going to get them imposed on this what
is the mechanism now to try and get some
sites brought forward as soon as
possible so we can fulfill the demand
Thank You councillor Cargill and you're
absolutely right this has been a process
that has been long in the gestation and
I can
all giving evidence in a planning appeal
as long ago as late 2014 with the
anticipation that we would we would have
a fully-formed
policy up and running you're absolutely
right one of the key drags if you will
is the question of sights and the last
call for sights did not bring forward
sights your point about the size and
makeup of traveler pitches and camps is
well made the evidence is that those
should be of a smaller and medium size
rather than having one very very large
sight to cover one you know a particular
district or or community and that then
brings challenges in terms of the number
of sites I think in addition to a
further call for sites I think there is
a discussion to be had with partner
agencies in the public sector who may
have land holdings that might be
appropriate
I think there's potentially some merit
in discussions with a range of those
partners across the district thank you
just to follow up on that particular
point I'm just in the back of my mind
real concern that the easy option is to
expand an existing site and as I said
that is that does have concerns to me
about some of the issues that we have
experienced on some of our larger sites
I think just to give that assurance to
you counselor Cargill our officers have
retained some external expertise the
resource so an officer at the county who
is well versed in the challenges around
gypsy and traveler sites and I think
there is a broader understanding that
best practice is that sites are our best
if they are relatively small and compact
I think we we are all aware we have one
particular site in the district which
would be regarded as being right at the
upper end of the the most optimal size
so I think this is more about new sites
than
particularly our keysight in expanding
that and hopefully that gives and that's
certainly the direction of travel for
officers okay any more comments
questions or observations from cabinet
councillor barker thank you it's just an
observation that because we are so short
of sights and because we haven't got to
stopping off points in formal stopping
off points are used and i've seen one in
my own borders and informal stopping off
point that has caused huge problems for
people in the locality if we are putting
into place the appropriate sights at
some point and get besides we do need to
have these stopping off ones as well I
think the observation is well made so
any more observations comments or
queries in that case councillor
Pemberton has read out the
recommendation and this is about
technical evidence to inform planning
decisions and policy development so can
I have your agreement to the
recommendation please cabinet thank you
moving on to item seven and surprisingly
this is councillor Pemberton again this
is the strategic housing land
availability assessment popularly known
as la councillor pended yes not sure
whether popularly known as it's correct
however members this is an item to bring
forward to receive what is called the
strategic housing land availability
assessment known as the slaw this is a
technical piece of evidence before
getting into the item members I do need
to bring your attention to an addendum
to the to the papers which will also
result in an amendment to the
recommendation
regrettably a site that had been
submitted for consideration under the
call for sites
which is land northwest of church farm
court Tysoe was in excluded from the the
papers that were published around the
slaw that sites has now been added in
he's available online members will also
have a hard copy the addition of this
site doesn't change any of the
overarching principles in the schleier
nor does it change any of the the
potential outcomes and outputs but it
will mean an additional recommendation
which I'll come to shortly again just to
provide some context for everyone
the schleier is a piece of technical
evidence and the principal reason for us
bringing forward this at this point is
that having had a core strategy put in
place there is a requirement that in
addition to having a sound course
strategy good quality neighborhood plans
which carry weight and I see
representatives of Kyneton who are very
very positive about the benefits of
neighborhood development plans to help
give them the weight and support that
they need in addition to having a core
strategy we need to be able to
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply and over and above that we need
to be able to demonstrate that we can
call on reserve sites should the
unforeseen and unwanted event arise that
sites that are currently allocated in
the core strategy and are proposed for
development do not for whatever reason
come forward just to give some assurance
to members of the public representatives
of parish councils we are obliged to do
this piece of work as an authority at
this point we can demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply we do have
a core strategy both of those have
resisted challenge in recent times in
addition we have a robust pipeline of
allocated sites and officers in
development control have a process to
ensure that
they are monitoring the larger sites to
ensure they come forward and are driven
forward in a timely fashion so in terms
of ever actually needing to get to these
sites insofar as one is able to say at
this point I have no expectation based
on our own need within the district of
having to bring forward these sites we
are obliged to do this this is a
technical piece of work and there will
be then a further a further stage in
terms of identification of reserve sites
so with that with that in mind the
recommendation is to receive the
strategic housing land availability
assessment as technical evidence to
inform pieing decisions and policy
developments notably the identification
of reserve housing sites and the site
allocations plan there is a dish there
is an additional recommendation that
there is provided a delegated authority
to the Planning Policy Manager in
liaison with the portfolio holder for
place to agree any minor technical and
factual corrections to the strategic
housing land availability assessment the
schlau which will enable us to bring in
the Tysoe sites into the documents and
you know clearly to tidy up any other
technical issues but we under no doubt
that if there was anything substantive
to change that would be brought back
through members of cabinet and at that
point I think I can see stands for
questions and also any questions or
comments councillor Perry Thank You
chair I would just like to have a bit
taraf occasion of when we can expect the
the calculation on the five-year housing
land supply and how that will dovetail
if this goes to cabinet at the end of
July because I think it'd be very
important to have be helpful to have
that information particularly in terms
of communicating it further around the
district of what the current position of
the five-year housing
- Thank You councillor Perry I'm just
looking towards John Kerr Ford perhaps
you might be able to give some clarity
as to win the next when we're next due
to declare our housing run supplied
numbers mr. kair furred welcome
I thank you leader its company in
progress for doing the work that
underpins it
we aim to publish it in July so a few
weeks off jumps repairing yeah I just I
just think it would be really helpful if
we've got that information when this
comes to full cabinet that's thank you
any more comments questions or
observations on item seven
in that case cabinet can we accept the
recommendation plus the addition that
councilor Pemberton outlined thank you
cabinet so moving on to item 8 which is
the stratford-upon-avon to honey ball
rail reinstatement indicative funding
appraisal and counselor Pemberton will
introduce the paper and then we'll ask
mr. Baxter to speak Thank You counsel
Thank You leader in chairman yes the
purpose of this item is to bring forward
the findings of a study in terms of the
stratford-upon-avon 200 or and rail
reinstatement in terms of an indicative
appraisal of funding options
I think perhaps at that point just to
allow mr. Baxter to to address cabinet
mr. Baxter do you want to come and use
microphone please
and please be aware that you've got
three minutes to speak and it will be
timed so just indicate when you are
ready to start please
Thank You mr. chair and fellow members
here yes this whole question has come up
yet again of the Hannibal rail link what
I'm going to do is just concentrate on
the summit some way section primarily
because it's too long that's sort of a
concept too and go into detail today
into certainly not in three minutes
if you start at the bottom of the
platform the southern end of the
platform of Stratford railway station
you got you will recall briar craft the
big housing development for elderly
people flats um whatever and you got the
limes residential area of housing for
those who are incapacitated
now the limes is 50 yards approximately
from the proposed rail link by our craft
is approximately 80 yards away so the
noise and the variation is going to be
pretty high to put it mildly
especially when the frequency of the
trains that have been proposed is three
times sorry
there's a 30 minute mother frequency
between
hapa 6:00 in the morning and 11 o'clock
at night you come down a little bit
further south now and you've got your
clothes on the top of summer some way
the beginnings of it trees to be cut
down there there's two enormous trees of
approximately 70 feet in height which
have housed bats which have been
registered with the k2 council as having
that and that was done last year
that's our protected species as you all
know those trees would be would have an
enormous visual impact an environmental
impact on their whole area if they have
to be cut down which they would if
anything goes through there whether it's
guided rail or or main rail system
whatever come a little bit further south
now into the beginning of something way
itself and you've got an area what is at
the moment is very peaceful and very
ideal for people to relax in stroll
around and whatever we did a survey
there two years ago there were 700
pedestrian movements and cycle movements
over a six hour period on several days
introduce us to go mr. box so now you've
got the big problem about pedestrian
crossings if you close one what's going
to happen to the other one it's going to
be you're gonna have to put up a bridge
a pedestrian bridge this is going to
have enormous visual and environmental
impacts on the whole area cutting its
thank you mr. gowdy
downs three minutes okay just coming now
to an end there's lowing the cutting to
be harvested or back to the beaches Eve
thank you I'm just finishing in the cell
you're not you've finished okay thank
you very much thank you thank you mr.
Baxter for your for your comments
remembers the the the report that is
before us is a further piece of work
that seeks to identify funding options
potential funding streams that might be
brought into play to reinstate a heavy
rail
between Stratford and honey born this
has been a potential aspiration at least
in some quarters for some considerable
time it has to be said that there is no
appetite as yet outlined by Network Rail
to bring forward a heavy rail option on
this line in terms of even moving to the
next stage of a business case which
would require what is called a grip for
study that would need some indication
from Network Rail that they have it even
on their long list of projects and we're
not even at that point my understanding
of the grip for process is that it would
be something of the order of five
hundred thousand pounds spent to prepare
the case so we're faced with some
challenges there is a case put forward
before bringing forward a mass transit
solution that links the rail network we
also have in the district a new
settlement being established at long
last in' and whilst we are already
building or proposing to build
infrastructure subject to planning
consent to support that that
infrastructure is unlikely to be the
only solution for the garden village and
so the the question for us is do we
merely accept this report and leave
things in essence and pardon the pun in
a siding or do we start to consider
whether there are any other options or
opportunities to achieve the same
outcome which is to increase
connectivity in and around the district
and to improve mass transport and to
reduce that residents reliance upon the
car
and to bring forward environmental
benefits that would accrue from that so
the second part of the recommendation in
addition to receiving the technical
report is that we should consider what
further investigations could be carried
out to establish whether there are
realistic and more fundable options
noting the at today's price is 111
million pounds worth of cots for heavy
rail which is the absolute floor of the
figure that it would end up as whether
we consider other options which might be
able to achieve similar positive
outcomes and the recommendation is
seeking support from cabinets to then
move forward with the potential for
other options to be considered and I
think at that point I shall just leave
it and take some further questions
questions comments observations
councillor Cargill thank you I've been
involved in this particular process for
a little while and I have to say I
cannot support a heavy rail option I
just don't think it's viable I can't
imagine what payback period would be
certainly not in many people's lifetimes
however I am keen to progress
alternative solutions now one of those
we've talked about guiding rail and and
light rail and things like that well I
don't know which was the better option
but there is a development at Quintin
where such technologies are actually
being developed and I would think it'd
be really quite quite relevant for us to
examine some of those as well and see
whether or not they would fit into this
particular solution I agree with you
entirely about getting cars off the road
and the most efficient method
and that would be for example battery I
think they've explored flywheel they're
looking at hydrogen technology all sorts
of things I would be very keen to
actually explore that with officers
Thank You councillor Cargill any of the
comments or observations councillor
Harvey I would have thought this is
something that we ought to encourage
quite quite seriously in the absence of
Network Rail being prepared to get
behind a heavy rail solution if that's
where they see the future then I think
given the pressures that we have within
Stratford and district on traffic
generally and we all know that the
population of the district is not going
down it's going to go up pressures are
going to increase and I think it's
incumbent upon the authority to explore
as many options that are reasonably
feasible to find out what our options
really are and I can't see any any good
reason why we shouldn't give councillor
Pepin and his team every support any
other comments of observations from
cabinet so are we minded to consider
whether further investigation should be
carried out on the potential to
reinstate the formal line for rail based
purposes excluding heavy rail agreed
upon me on the provider that if there
are any additional costs which we would
need to incur to undertake that could be
subject to a further report back to
cabinet so subject so any further costs
that may be incurred in doing that if
there are costs and they are substantial
it comes back to cabinet are we all
agreed on that as well thank you
so that was councillor Pemberton's last
paper so we now move on to item 9 which
is capital L turn 20
1819 in capital of slippage councillor
harvey new boy sorry
Thank You chairman and leader the
purpose of this paper is twofold first
to inform members of the amount of money
spent by the council on capital
expenditure items in the last accounting
period that's up to the end of March
2019 this amounted to 3.3 million pounds
as shown in table 1 I draw attention to
paragraph 1 point 5 and the underlying
details set out in Appendix 1 for the
year ended 31st March 2019 not 2018 as
stated in the paper for which I
apologize second purpose is to see the
cabinet's agreement to amounts of
capital expenditure that could not be
spent in 2018 19 to be carried forward
to be made available for commitment in
the current financial year of 2019 20
these are referred to as items of
slippage an unfortunate term I think
which I'll discuss with mr. Buckland
and but it's accepted and that amount to
four million pounds is summarized in
paragraph two point three point one and
accounted for by head and the relevant
functions in appendix three brief data
brief details of the reasons supporting
significant items that are sought to be
carried forward are set out in
paragraphs two point one one to two
point one eleven there are various
reasons for each of the amounts
requested to be carried forward which
I'm sure mr. Buckland if required would
be happy to provide for example
paragraph two point one five requests
that are carried forward of 60,000
pounds in an instance where the timing
of the installation of the hostile
vehicle mitigation measures is
controlled by Warwickshire County
Council in the case of item two point
one point seven without the action
concerning the Greek center having been
settled it's not being possible to
undertake the intended work on that
facility
given current practices therefore I ask
members to accept the recommendation
that the capital budget for 2019-20 be
increased by four million and fifty six
thousand two hundred and eighteen pounds
for the reasons set out in the paper
Thank You mr. chairman the questions
comments observations from cabinet if
there are non then the recommendation on
page 41 so that councillor Harvey
outlined are we happy with that members
of cabinet thank you so moving on
councillor Harvey once again draft
revenue out turn 2018-19 and revenue
slippage Thank You mr. chairman the
leader the purpose of this paper are
twofold
and first to set out for the cabinet
members the areas in which the council's
net position in relation to the service
provision has varied over the past year
when set against the relevant budgeted
figure second to seek the cabinet's
agreement to the way in which the
financial consequences are the
variations identified should be dealt
with as they impact on the council's
general revenue reserves paragraph 1.71
identifies that the council's budgeted
total net revenue expenditure for
2018-19
was 14 million and 4 thousand pounds
the latest estimated out turn for net
revenue expenditure for 2018-19 however
is that it was 14.5 for 8 million pounds
in other words there's been a net under
spend of the difference between these
two figures of 544 thousand pounds table
1 in paragraph 1 point 7 2 sets out the
detail of the amounts and the reasons
for the variations that have led to this
outcome the variations illustrate the
vagaries of the budgeting process the
largest single positive net variation
with the generation of revenue above the
budgeted amount of 345 thousand pounds
from car parking charges due to amongst
other things a long long forgotten hot
summer and the implications it had for
visitor numbers similarly investment
income was significantly higher than had
been budgeted in part due to the
retention of balances due to delays in
the capacitor and to take elements of
the intended capital program table one
also identifies and paragraph one point
nine one explains the rationale for the
five areas that's CCTV corporate
communications corporate budget policy
and housing where transfers of budget to
the current year
slippage totaling two hundred and twelve
thousand five hundred pounds are
requested paragraph one point five
points out that budgeted capital
expenditure of one point two six five
million pounds has been held pending the
delivery of identified capital projects
it requested that the whole of this
amount be transferred to an earmarked
reserved within the 2019-20
budget D if you're still with me the
cumulative effect of the under spend of
accurately five hundred and forty three
thousand six hundred and eighty nine
pounds and they requested transfers of
two hundred and twelve and a half
thousand pounds revenue and one point
two sixty five million pounds capital
financing on the general revenue
reserves is set out in table two of
paragraph one point eight one this
explains how the council's revenue
position has on the basis of the record
recommendations one two four made in
this paper increased from nine point
nine million pounds on the first of
April
2018 to ten point 1 million pounds on
the first of April 2019 subject to any
questions cabinet members may wish to
ask it's recommended therefore that
recommendations one to four setter has
set out in the paper are agreed thank
you for that comprehensive introduction
councillor Harvey are there any
questions by members of cabinet and once
again councillor Cargill anyone comment
on I do fully accept all the
the reasons for Sophia's etc and
including for example the great center
which is in my my locale that we are
seeing slippage ISM and does that mean
we're not delivering our projects and
therefore these things just way outside
about our domain
I think councillor Cargill an awful lot
of the slippage on projects is down to
issues outside of our control which
personally I found incredibly
frustrating but the grief Center will be
a good example
CCTV where I know mr. Buckland did an
awful lot of work on due diligence
before we could proceed so these things
are not under our control and do lead to
some slippage I think there is a point
at which we do need to kind of put more
emphasis on actually delivering but that
is something we are well aware of any
more comments or questions came that
sorry councillor Harvey in that case the
recommendations 1 to 4 on page 59 is
coming it happy with those
recommendations thank you members of
cabinet and prudential indicators
2018-19 outturn position once again
councillor Harvey Thank You mr. chairman
and leader the purpose of this paper is
to report to cabinet on the council's
position at the end of the last
financial reporting year on a number of
prudential indicators that it is
required to monitor the paper is a
statutory paper in other words it
reports in a way that it is required of
the council and it is presented for
noting the essential point to bear in
mind is that the council's current
policy is that it should remain free of
debt when considering how it will
finance its capital
in fact rather than incurring interest
charges
the council's net revenue stream is
positive and generates interest as set
out in the table in paragraph five point
one to the council is required to
monitor its capital expenditure set
against prudential indicators at the
table in paragraph five point five three
indicates the council's capital program
of seven point 1 million pounds was
under spent last year by three point
seven million pounds as a result there
are no areas of concern in relation to
relevant prudential indicators on which
to report subject to any questions from
cabinet members it is recommended that
the contents of this paper be noted any
questions or comments members of cabinet
take that as a no vain the
recommendation is that the report be
received can we receive the report
members of cabinet thank you so final
item 12 OSC task and finish group report
on preventing evictions and the name on
this is councillor Barker Thank You mr.
chairman I think it's a real privilege
to be bringing this before you because I
was the chairman of scrutiny when we did
all the work in considering the
recommendations and it was a really
really intense piece of work that I
think will make a difference to the
people of this district the following
recommendations have been presented
you'll see them on page 79 items 1 to 4
may I just say that we thought I'd like
to remove item 4 at the moment so that
it can be considered as part of the
budgetary procedure in the rest of the
year but that anyone who thinks that
it's not going to be in there will have
another thing coming because I shall
fight rather vigorously for it because
the three-year funding arrangement for
the court desk work
in my opinion bifel there are celled
that one to you already so you've all
had an opportunity to see the report and
I'll just go through the recommendations
we can agree them on block block I think
you say firstly the introduction of
process of evaluation of the housing
management approach as part of the
process of identifying partners for new
build social housing this is as a result
of the work that we did and the
conversations we have with various
providers item 2 the adoption of a
council policy statement on the
Prevention of homelessness yet to be
drafted item 3 the introduction of a
customer referral form to triage
financially vulnerable customers to
specialist support services and then
four to be deferred to a later date
hopefully can all agree those
recommendations ok any questions queries
or comments members of council ACOG you
just one comment from me and notice on
page 88 that comes the number of
experienced landlords retired on us or
selling their properties and a
consistent
consequent reduction in landlord
expertise I've heard that from elsewhere
as well so with that any more comments
councillor Perry Thank You chair I would
also like to endorse this report I think
it's excellent I would just like to make
an observation
obviously there are considerable
legislation changes going on in the
rental market at the moment impacting
hugely on private landlords we're more
than likely because of the tenant fee
legislation that came into force on Sat
day and there are moose for consultation
on the eviction of tenants out of
private rented properties that the
government is will be undertaking a
consultation the net result of all these
things we are already being seen there
are a number of private landlords coming
out of investing in property which could
have an impact on increased rentals in
the area and also shortage it's just as
an observation in line with all this
work and I think they they are key
points that we could have impact on the
district in the next year or two I think
your points are well made councillor
Perry and I'm sure it is something we
will actually keep a very close eye on
with that if there are no further
comments or questions then
recommendations 1 2 3 our council happy
with those recommended cabinet happy
with those recommendations thank you
having it to the on block items which
are the strategic policy Advisory Group
minutes the member development working
group minutes that is it so our cabinet
members happy with those minutes to
accept them a grade of no items of
urgent business and the final item on
the agenda is start times of meetings
for 2019 24 easiest way to start these
are people happy with the start time of
3:30 in that case cabinet we've agreed
that the start times continue at 3:30
thank you and with that I get to hit
this meeting closed